oh tiger belly should sponsor a prom
next year
where we should invite like 80 people
and we should go
we should have just a prom theme you
know and just have this like adult prom
right
and then george was like yeah yeah we
should do that because um
i never had one and what do you mean you
never had one
and because he was a seventh-day
adventist
they weren't even allowed to dancing was
not allowed they have banquets they have
junior senior banquet a banquet
banquet it's like you lived in footloose
my whole religion is footloose
honestly so so dancing is the devil's
way
uh pretty much dancing well it leads to
uh you know carnal desires
wow tell the job because they don't
believe you yeah no
jabberwockies don't for sure for sure so
like what did you guys do ellen
degeneres doesn't she dances all the
time yeah
what is what do you do at these banquets
we would get bust into some uh
do you say we get roast beef
good vegetarian options we'd all sit
down you were all vegetarian yeah you
they don't eat meat
yeah then oh my god sit at large
communal tables you'd like hope you had
like some friends and not the nerds in
your table
you're no good person alert amber alert
you're all nerves excuse me news flash
there's no new news
there's no good people you know why are
you just amber alert
that's like a child being kidnapped i
don't know i don't know
yeah amber alert i'm sick i'm sick guys
i'm just
trying to figure it out you know what i
mean but you're all nerds by the way
yeah you can't be cool do you did all
that restriction
make your childhood memories fond
oh i didn't know what i was missing at
the time so it's only later on that i
kind of wished i'd gone to like a big
high school with like the
you know like have the football
experience or other things that i missed
out on because we didn't even have like
sports
we didn't have sports against other
schools sports aren't allowed either
um we did intramurals so it's like five
on five flag football
yummy oh flag football too so no contact
so nothing against other teams we didn't
have competition against other
like schools also everyone's a winner in
life yeah
except we i did play like optimus soccer
what is that
it's just like a local soccer league
that's not affiliated with the school
but we had all of ours
i thought it was like a transfer
transformer and we'd play the local like
high school like the team that had most
of the adventists on it would play the
local high school
to miss soccer it's obviously always
loose
we had like so many quarters on our team
yeah we were like had good individual
players yeah
but they weren't good over we didn't
play as a team because we didn't like
play outside was there any hot chicks
at your church growing up like seven for
sure there was oh yeah
rebellious ones um not too many rebels
can i can i have i have a little
confession and don't take offense to it
okay baby but there's a documentary
called uh devil's playground okay
it's about the amish and then they have
that what what what is that that little
room springer
yeah where they can park crazy crazy
right but there's this one girl that's
in that document is really pretty
right and then she just leaves the
church and she moves to florida
and i used to have this fantasy this is
way back to you she would find you
that i would like i'm the first guy i'm
the first guy that she runs into
i show her all these tricks